hey friends its January 26th I'm
chastity and just like you I also miss
Jess but she'll be back next week for
now you're stuck with me whoops here's
the news first up Hideo Kojima spoke
more about his game death surrounding
and also commented on his split with
Konami today Okajima still can't say
much about his mysterious game death
stranding but he did tell BBC News me
that it may not be like what he's made
before we want this game to be something
that people can get into easily but
after an hour or two they'll start to
notice something a little different
Kojima said it's not like anything
they've played before Kojima went on to
say that he wants to be seen as a risk
taker someone who tries new things even
if that means losing fans bands that
everyone remembers take risks he said
they constantly changed their music from
previous albums adapting and evolving
through the ages they might lose some
fans along the way but they bring in new
ones he added that's the kind of
approach I want to take with my new game
Kojima also commented on his split with
ex publisher Konami in 2015 the director
went through a public breakup from the
company he'd worked with for nearly 30
years I have more freedom now because
the final decision comes down to me he
told BBC News beat this company is not
listed on the stock exchange so we don't
need to worry about pleasing investors
we can just concentrate on making good
games next up a new avengers game and
it's coming from the developers of deus
ex and tomb raider Square Enix and
Marvel have announced a multi-game
partnership the first part of which is
for a new avengers game from tomb raider
dev crystal dynamics and deus ex studio
itís Montreal a trailer for the entitled
project features narration from a
mysterious character the trailer shows
Thor's hammer Captain America's shield
and iron man's hand though it looks like
they all have seen better days the
tagline reassembles suggests that they
have been scattered a press release from
Square Enix reads the Avengers project
is being designed for gamers worldwide
and will be packed with all the
characters environments and iconic
moments that have thrilled longtime fans
of the franchise featuring a completely
original story it will introduce a
universe gamers can play in for years to
come Square Enix has said more details
on the Avengers project in other games
will be announced in 20
team and finally the pc version of me no
kuni to revenant Kingdom has been
announced level five confirmed today
that knee no kuni to revenant kingdom
will be coming to PC as well as to ps4
as part of an interview with gamespot
level 5 CEO akihiro hino confirmed the
existence of the pc version saying
having a pc version means the game is
more accessible for everyone overseas as
a fan of Western RPGs I think our games
need to be offering a similarly great
experience utilizing things like an open
world and a stress-free battle system it
should feel familiar for all gamers
Hannah also spoke about how Studio
Ghibli's legacy would be represented in
knee no kuni too jibley films mostly
deal with families and ever since we
teamed up with jibley in the previous
games I really want to focus on the
bonds of family publisher Bandai Namco
hasn't announced a release date for knee
no kuni to revenant Kingdom merely
confirming it will be available sometime
in 2017 and hey if you didn't get into
the for honor closed beta be sure to
check out our gameplay clips which are
up right now go go go and also subscribe
because we have lots of for honor stuff
coming your way I'm chassis and I'll see
you tomorrow
[Music]